You go to Durham, North Carolina,
the Durham public school system has half a dozen schools. They are,
they close their schools. Schools are not reopening. Okay.
So instead what they're doing, it's all online learning,
but they are operating six learning centers
and the learning centers are going to allow kids to come in and, you know,
with their laptops and do the online learning.
Do you know where the learning centers are?
The learning centers at prison? What? No.
Well County prison sort of.
[Inaudible].
You're in a reality war. I think that's what we call it. The culture war.
But I think it's starting to become the reality war.
That seems to me where we're.
And the issue that you have.
I don't know if the first one of these happened before you went off the grid,
but you had an image of an MSNBC reporter standing in front of.
Oh, Ali Velshi yes. Ali bell. She's standing in front of thing.
There's nothing to see here. It's mostly peaceful. Uh, dude,
there's a building exploding on the fire.
Yeah. We got another one on CNN. About a week ago. We got another,
it was the same thing. It was like, you could have just swapped the reporters.
It was the exact same thing, same story, but.
Why they can't stop?
They can't stop because they're in so deep that to stop,
to stop that wheel that we were talking about before they would have to,
they they'd have to commit Harry Carey. You know what I mean?
They'd have to just impale themselves on their own sword.
That would be the only way they would have to say yes,
we have been artists, Epic,
artists decades. Speaking of arts,
like is the New York times still a newspaper or did that thing wrap up then it
was, I mean, it was crumbling. I don't think it's been a newspaper.
They had announced they weren't going to do news anymore.
Or they were going to run it by like a seventh grader. So yeah,
the trans seventh grader was going to be able to correct things or something
like that. All of the editors of the New York times now have to be trans seven.
You have to trans all the kids. Well, actually,
so the New York times is still whatever it is.
I'm not gonna say it's a newspaper, but it's still whatever it is.
But on the school front, there is some really weird stuff going on. So.
Right. Our school's opening like what's going on there?
Do we have schools anymore? So.
Let's look at New York, obviously giant school system.
I come from the New York public. It comes as a matter of fact, it was right.
So New York has no plan to reopen restaurants.
Nope, no plan. And he said maybe June of next year, they just don't know.
They're just shooting from the hip.
However schools are going to be back in session. It was just today.
It was delayed. So now they're going to push it. It was supposed to.
Wait. So schools are not starting in New York next. Well,
I guess it would be today. They have delayed it.
But they, they didn't.
They got a lot of flack for saying the schools have to reopen and no one
understood. Why are the schools? It made perfect sense to me.
You still want to indoctrinate the kids you've seen.
In a good place to warehouse push the indoctrination costs.
That's so weird that in outside of New York, you to Durham,
North Carolina, the Durham public school system has half a dozen schools.
They are, they close their schools. Schools are not reopening. Okay?
So instead what they're doing, it's all online learning,
but they are operating six learning centers
and the learning centers are going to allow kids to come in and you know,
with their laptops and do the online learning.
Do you know where the learning centers are?
The learning centers at prison? What know?
Well County prison, sort of.
The learning centers are in the schools, which are closed.
Nobody gets better days.
It gets better. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I know it's hard because I'm just getting back on the grid.
So maybe my English isn't maybe what you're telling me is Durham has closed the
schools.
Totally closed. Then they've.
Announced that these centers were open where the kids can come with their
laptops to do remote learning, to do remote learning.
And that is at the schools that are closed. That's correct.
Yeah. It makes sense. Doesn't it?
But it actually w w what you're probably saying is though the only way that
would work is if the school district charged the parents more money to come use
the schools,
which are closed to do the online learning from the schools that you can't go
to. Right. That would, that would make sense.
So in order to use the remote learning centers at the schools,
parents have to pay $140 a week, plus $35 registration fee.
Unless you're a bureaucrat who works for the government,
at which case you get a discount.
What's the, what's the daily wire, uh, policy on the word.
Uh, Oh, it's, it's your show. My friend. We are right? Yeah.
You're bananas. Insane. But again,
do you see what I'm saying? That there is nothing too stupid for this movement.
Yeah. There is nothing too insane for this movement. Yeah.
It will eat away and rot out.
Every whatever institution allows this stupidity in it
will destroy it.
And that is what it sounds like is happening in Durham,
North Carolina speaking, but wait a minute,
why would they need more money to do that?
I assume everyone's still paying taxes. They didn't tax rebates to the people.
They're all still paying taxes.
You're paying the exact amount of taxes that you always paid for.
The public schools. The public schools are then closed,
but then less people will be there. Correct.
So you'd think you would be able to save a little money,
but then you still got to charge. So now, so in effect,
only people with money will be able to send their kids to those schools.
But I thought they were also against school choice there.
And their brain is exploding.
Here's the way to make sense of it. Has the government agency ever said,
give me less money. Yeah. Has that ever happened?
No. It's not the story of humanity. No, they run literally. I mean,
people don't believe this,
but most government agencies run on a thing where they have to hit their budget.
Otherwise their budget gets cut. Nobody could run a business like that.
I can't run my business like that, where I'm like,
I have to spend every freaking cent that I have.
Otherwise I'm not going to magically get well, because I'm not giving money.
I have to earn money. You know? So,
so what I do is I save a certain amount in my business each year,
so we can continue to grow or we might have some problems and then we can figure
it out.
That's, that's completely foreign.
That's completely foreign to a government economic genius over here.
I know you are. And you know, actually speaking of, kind of naughty words,
going blue. Yeah. I have to read you. There is a song that is.
Bust out your glasses, like, excuse me, sir.
Now that we're going blue. So.
There's a new song that's taken over the world.
And when I say taken over the world, I mean like, this is the story, okay.
This is the story. So I don't even know, you know, I don't go blue on my show.
I'm very clean, clean, cut. I don't wear socks in my loafers. You know,
I try to be, I can't say the name of this,
of this song without going blue.
Be better. And you're hosting right now.
So I want you to do what you think is right. Would it be right?
Or if I just read it straight away.
I would feel much better if you, so the song is called whap whap,
right? It's my, it's my Cardi. Yeah.
W a P it's by Cardi B and this song, I mean,
this is like at the, now the, the Anthem, the feminist Anthem.
Cardi B. I'm not totally sure who she is,
but I know she was like fighting with people right before I went there.
She, she supported Bernie Sanders.
Long nails. I think she, and I.
Think that's racist for you to say that, but yes, she does have long nails.
So here's what this is. This song has just taken over everyone.
This is everyone's taken over.
So I'll just, I guess I'll just read a little bit, yeah. Whores in this house,
there, some horrors in this house, there's some horrors in this house.
There's some whores in this house, whole up. I said, certified freak,
seven days a week. Wet. Make that pull out game week.
That's good. Yeah. And then the chorus. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You with some sweet, bring a bucket and mop for this.
Mop for this. Oh, bring a bucket and not for this way. Cause he,
you gotta mop up. Then give me everything you got for this wet.
Uh,
I'm going to not do the next paragraph because that's where they'll come for me.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.